لدينا بعض الأصوات الجديدة المزعجة التي
تُظهر اليأس مستوى
اليأس لدى امرأة أفغانية عازبة
مع وصول طالبان إلى كابول ، لقد
انتهيت حياتي
ولا أعرف
أنني لست متأكدًا مما إذا كان بإمكاني
الاحتفاظ برسائلك  بعد الآن ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم
على كل شيء كيم ، لكنني أعتقد أنه
كذلك ولن ينجح الأمر
، ثم تأخرتم كثيرًا
في
التحكم في الأمور ، لقد فات
الأوان للتحكم في الموقف ، أنا آسف
ولكن جهودكم
لا تعني أي شيء بعد الآن
، فالشيء هو أنه
إذا بقينا هنا لمدة ساعة أخرى
، فستحدث مذبحة ، فأنا أقول
لك أنه ستكون هناك مذبحة
سيُقتل الجميع هنا من فضلك.
تحت الهجوم هناك حشد كبير من
الغوغاء يهاجموننا وهم
مسلحون ربما يكون بينهم بعض مقاتلي طالبان
وهم أم ثم مثل
الآلاف منهم ليس فقط بضع
مئات بل الآلاف منهم أنا
حقا  خائفة و
III لا أريد أن أكون هنا بعد الآن  أو
لأنني خائف حقًا من أنني
خائف على حياتي وحياة عائلتي
وأيضًا
أنا أموت من القلق وأؤكد أيضًا أنه
أمر مرهق حقًا إنه
حقًا مرهق حقًا ولا أعرف
ماذا أفعل
الآن يجب أن نلاحظ أن CNN لا يمكنها
التحقق بشكل مستقل
مما تُرى المرأة على هذا الشريط
على الأرض ولكن انضم إلي الآن
المحامية الدولية لحقوق الإنسان
كيمبرلي موتلي التي هي على اتصال
بتلك المرأة الأفغانية التي سمعت عنها للتو
وتلك المرأة  حاليًا في
مختبئ ،
أنت تعرف أن كيم امرأة واحدة ولكن
هذا ما نسمعه من الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين هم على اتصال بالأفغان
هذه لحظة بلحظة بالنسبة لهم
وهم غير متأكدين من أنهم
سيخرجون من هذا
أعني بريانا تمامًا ، أشكرك على
استضافتي إنها قنبلة نووية لحقوق
الإنسان ، وأنا أتلقى الكثير
من الرسائل من النساء والرجال على وجه الخصوص الذين
يخافون على حياتهم ، النساء اللاتي
عملن معك يعرفن المجتمع الدولي
وكذلك الرجال الذين كانوا  أنت
تعلم أن الجيش عمل جنبًا إلى جنب مع
جيشنا أو أولئك الذين هم متقدمون من siv ،
إنه وضع مرعب
كما قلت إنه يتغير
بسرعة كبيرة ودقيقة إلى دقيقة